what's up banners up dudes in the year
since you did worth it tattoos googling
mine a lot of empty cannabis right here
the follow-up to worth it about dinars I
do yeah let's do this where the run stop
last video you haven't seen it you don't
watch that first you are on your way
right now to get three different tattoos
at three drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it at this price the first time
we're doing a sequel tag - oh I'm
talking about what are we doing today
we're gonna check out your tattoos see
how the tactics have cut up over time
when you go to tattoo you're excited
it's like oh my god these are so awesome
but a year later was it really worth it
I saw us that that 20% of people regret
their tattoo I wouldn't be going to get
a new tattoo today if I regretted it
they're about to get a $1000 I do a
little bit behind the scenes of last
video
Ben was questioning his life decisions
we're on our way right now to Venice
Beach actually to get a tattoo I would
much rather be buying a meal with you
$300 sushi yeah we're going to Venice
Beach for the freakin tattoo like the
last video our first location dropped
out
so we're driving around the beach trying
to find the location what the hell are
we doing right now that is first of all
good cuz you're gonna have this on your
body but if your life yeah and second of
all gonna let us film right on the spot
would we be able to feel the cold
sensation luckily we found a good spot
but that 30-minute drive he kept asking
me if you you thinking a mistake you're
just smiling good inside I can tell you
yeah I felt really bad I wanted to see
the quality of the tattoo is and how the
ink held up over time they've held up
great that $80.00 one is still in mint
condition yeah it's crazy they're like
bright quality work and a second tattoo
there was a head body electric faded he
had the cover so much ground with all
that ink that maybe that's the reason
why it faded a little bit more full
disclosure I was supposed to go back and
get another detail passed I didn't go so
there's a bit of an asterisk over the
second shop Speak Easy tattoo tell me
about that one the quality of work is
stellar its immaculate dude it's just a
beautiful piece I get compliments on it
all over the place I am really happy
when I look in the mirror and see that
the theme for my next piece I actually
had the idea during the first video what
do you want to do for your first tattoo
I'm thinking something related to
Breaking Bad they've got this teddy bear
I actually asked Scott last year if he
could do this probably would have to
pass on that concept
well let's I mean but now let's see if
he's come around taking us to the secret
lair of speakeasy tattoo I am so ready
to sit and watch you get a tattoo for
another five hours I'm not gonna be
worrying at all
hello are you nice to see you
[Music]
God didn't see a hey we had to see you
two guys back so we're bad thanks for
having us again I can't believe the
years past story since the video came
out how is your business been doing how
have you been doing oh man when the
video did come out I was up riding dirt
bikes with my daughter and I didn't have
a signal I get off the mountain and
there was a little bit of chaos probably
now 50% of my business became more of a
global business just a local business
the coolest thing for me out of all this
I mean I got an amazing piece of art but
just seeing how it Sloan up your
business and impact of your life that's
the coolest thing about this job to be
able to help an artist who deserves
their recognition so I have to say thank
you to you guys you exposed my art and
helped me no can't thank you guys to
know it's been one year later now right
when you have a tattoo for a year or
five years ten years how are you
defining how worth it it was I'm looking
at his arm and not gonna lie your tattoo
is right it's really still so detailed
it looks great but as an artist like
from your perspective what is bringing
that value when you have attend to them
longevity is a major thing if a year
went by and you came in and your tattoo
was needing serious touch-up from being
blown out or evaded that means that I'm
not really precise with my craft but as
I see it I'm very happy with it and I'm
my biggest critic I definitely treat
each tattoo very specifically to that
person it's all very customized to their
skin to what will look good with the
skin color painting is no problem
because the canvas is always the same
doing a tattoo you might do this same
tattoo on someone else might not work as
well the reason been had to wait so long
is because he wanted this bear not
really feeling the breaking bad bear and
I wasn't you know we need to really sit
down and hone in on how I'm gonna
execute them
finish your half sleeve off so that you
can be walking around with a really
complete feeling arm we're gonna go in
talk about all this stuff and make sure
that we both are collaborating on
something
that's mind blowing so the breaking bad
bear we're on that can I plead my case
let's at least talk about it
Breaking Bad to me represents just the
pinnacle of what creativity and artistry
can be it's what I strived to be so I
want an element from that show on my
body just to see where the bar is and
try to get there makes sense I love that
show
the main character Walter White
basically causes this plane to crash and
the wreckage of the crash is this pink
teddy bear
floating in a pool it's all like
disfigured and burnt the bear in the
show to me represents the chaos that
come as a result of drugs I have battled
with drug addiction for quite some time
and I'm currently winning that battle
that's great to hear I want to remind
myself that although I may be winning
the battle now it's something I always
have to be cautious of and never let my
guard down this is amazing yeah thank
you for sharing this source
I definitely feel new really being
connected to it I'm not into just doing
the bear we have space wonkavator the
moon we got the Peter Pan stars you
could just be I got it damn what about
we take the bear and put him in a
spacesuit a rehabilitating bear in space
what do you think about that a space
it'll all connect and then he'll be in
space yeah that's a good start
like I feel that one other thing an
element now I don't know how you would
incorporate this but one of my best
friends passed away a few weeks ago very
unexpectedly right now I don't know if
we could incorporate his name in there
like I mean I don't really do text with
the art usually the art needs to speak
for itself maybe there's a way that I
can inscribe the spacesuit what are the
initials p-n-p-n at Mastro's Pat Nast
Rome how about this you know NASA the
NASA symbol we turned that it in tune
Astro on the bear suit right there yes
that is awesome that's the missing piece
right there that's Owen compass
let's do that hat is someone who
struggled with substance abuse
himself and he was not you know one of
the lucky ones who gets to recover it's
another reminder just to stay the path
van I'm excited I'm honored to be a part
of this one of my heartstrings man oh
man if I can be open about talking about
this maybe other people can too because
it was not easy for me to speak up and
get help but once I did it was the best
thing that ever happened to me nothing
to be ashamed of nothing to hide I wear
it all on my sleeve he fire yes that's
good come on
[Music]
I'm excited for you to check out your
design I went a little further and I
actually did a quick oil painting so I'm
stoked for you to check it out and drop
it down Wow oh my god it even has master
on there that is amazing cuz I'm so glad
that you took a gear to talk me into
doing this bear so now I'm really
inspired by this guy
[Applause]
Nicole is my stencil maker and she did a
great job so he's gonna go the best
facing up a little bit so you look down
you'll be able to look down and you see
his eye peering out good stencil a
little duplication but overall it's
gonna work just fine I like it an astro
bar right yes as soon as I got in
treatment I was in the car and the
Incubus song pardon me
came on that song had he's developed it
at the top of his lungs and I was
thinking god I wonder what Pat's up to
right now okay right here and I was
picturing and singing this song at the
top of his lungs and an hour later I get
a phone call saying Pat died an hour ago
so at the same time that I was hearing
that song and thinking about Pat it was
the exact moment that he passed away
it's crazy yes I take it like that was
his spirit like coming through the radio
to say goodbye to me
[Music]
[Music]
I'm loving this thing yeah a really
coming full circle getting into this
mode of just being able to confidently
make marks and know that it's all gonna
work out really fun so much fun yeah
last
[Music]
[Music]
we are finished for today oh damn never
seen a tattoo like that
[Music]
now that's refreshing this is insane
Scott you outdid yourself it's like
better than I could have ever dreamed of
it's just simply beautiful that I'm so
lucky to wear this piece of art you are
just the man thank you so much my
pleasure town bring a life into that so
what's the price tag on this like four
hours so I'm 1,000 that's it
safe time next year yeah we'll give me
give me a little time if you want
another bear or anything we need at
least a couple years for me to sit on it
[Music]